all right in the wake of this
announcement somebody needs to meme
force ghost Yoda having a stack of DVDs
of Game of Thrones and the books next to
him glancing over the books and going
read the review page turners they were
not I swear one of these days I'll be
done talking about Star Wars so before I
get into talking about this news I'm
gonna clarify something first
I originally as I was planning to do my
schedule the next review for the next
but the most recent black lightning
episode would have gone today I think
I've actually got a drop the Black
Lightning episode reviews I'm not
dropping the show I'm not stopping
watching and I'm still enjoying it but
the thing is right now I'm cranking em
videos out of pace that is really hard
to keep up and and something's got to
give and like unless something drastic
happens in the show that I'm like oh I
need to talk about that I'm gonna drop
the episode by episode with that one
maybe I'll do a wrap-up once the first
season is over but if you were waiting
on the rest of those sorry so for the
rest of you who clicked on this because
of what it actually says I'm gonna talk
about star wars so we've got more new
Star Wars films announced not a huge
shocker
I mean Disney didn't pay for this
franchise so that they could make you
know three more films and a couple of
spin-offs they want this to go on in
perpetuity for as long as humanly
possible so the news is is that they
have tapped the writing producing team
behind Game of Thrones the duo that have
been heading that show for its entirety
and they are going to be writing and
producing a new series of Star Wars
films this is separate from the numbered
saga which official word is wraps up
with episode 9 and it is also separate
from the trilogy that Rian Johnson is
working on that was announced a few
months back so there's a number of
things to think about this so let me
kind of jump in and clear out the
obvious cynical way to deal with this
so this
dick in me says okay well when you said
you were bringing the saga to a close
you literally just met the Skywalker
saga because you know you you're still
gonna make these Star Wars movies
forever and if I was in a really
pessimistic mood part of me might say I
bet you part of the reason they're
tapping these guys now and having them
work on something and they're not just
going with Rian Johnson shows you on its
own is they don't want to put all their
eggs in that basket now whether that's
because they're at they've actually lost
any faith in him or they just want to
have more than one thing going so the
entire franchise isn't dependent on
whatever he makes either way it's
probably a little bit of a calculation
than that I think part of what makes me
I don't want to say nervous but that I'm
now gonna be watching out for is is this
basically gonna be the end of the a Star
Wars story movies and I don't say that
like well I enjoy rogue one much like
the force awakens people have started to
like crap on it after the fact I still
like that we watched it recently I think
it's still good but you know it had a
troubled production Han Han Solo that
movie is had a troubled production and
if that one underperforms
I feel like they're setting because what
what would have made sense before is you
know let the saga end and then you've
got this new trilogy from Rian Johnson
and you've got the you know Side Story
movies that seems like enough to have
basically two series going I'm you know
Ryan's new trilogy and the side thing so
if they're bringing in this that to me
says they're letting the side stories
die and part of me doesn't care because
even though I like rogue one it's not
amazing and with solo I'd I've always
thought that was a bad idea
but another part of me is real bummed
out about that the idea that they would
stop trying because I honestly think
that the concept behind those things
have completely detached self-contained
complete stories set in the Star Wars
universe
was a good idea I still think it's a
good idea they weren't do
doing it well but that's not a concept I
want to see die cuz I mean amongst other
things that's probably how we might have
one day gotten our obi-wan Kenobi movie
and even that I'm not like necessarily
I've been waiting for that for so long
but like there's a lot of stuff to be
milk there there's a lot of good
self-contained stories that do not have
to be part of some bigger epic thing
that can be told they just they just
didn't pick great ones and now they're
gonna let I think honestly a fertile
idea kind of fall by the wayside or at
least that's the impression that I have
in regards to all this this does really
seem to be confirming and backing up the
notion that episode 9 will be the end of
the numbered saga the end of the
Skywalker story and that I'm ok with I'm
ok with that for a number of reasons and
no it's not just because I didn't like
the last Jedi and now like I want the
series to die I'm not that bitter but I
do kind of think that trying to like
perpetuate the Skywalker saga
specifically is limiting in terms of
what you can do where you can go where
you're allowed to go with it and I think
actually in many ways the reaction to
the last Jedi bears that out because
again I didn't like the results from
Rian Johnson trying to go somewhere
different with the Skywalker story and a
sizeable and very vocal part of the fan
base rejected that soundly because they
don't want new directions from the
Skywalker story specifically so it makes
sense to put that to bed if you actively
want to go in new directions so that
you're not you're not running the risk
of yeah I was gonna say tainting me of
this family legacy but hey I feel like
that's that's harsher than I want to be
but that I can't think of something else
so we'll go with that
so I'm perfectly okay with episode 9
being the last time that we deal the
Skywalker's in any real direct fashion I
think it is it is better to close that
story because otherwise it's just like
does everything revolve around this
family forever really and I don't I
don't enjoyed that that kind of
storytelling so I'm totally fine with
letting that
be closed off and we still get Star Wars
stories that are separate from that now
of course we have zero indication of
what it is they're gonna be making we do
know they're not gonna be working on it
until Game of Thrones wraps up so that
means they're not even gonna get started
on this till next year
but that's still going to give them
plenty of time because Han Solo comes
out this year and Episode nine comes out
2019 one would probably presume that
Rian Johnson's first new movie comes out
2020 I don't think that's that's too
much of a long shot depending on how far
along he is on a script on that and so
we're probably looking at 2021 for the
for our new entry in this new series and
I do find that interesting that with
Rian Johnson's they did say trilogy and
this they're saying series so that to me
is another sort of little indicator
which is Rian Johnson is going at his
project with an ending like he's got
beginning metal and he's telling
something in three parts however he's
deciding to break it up however he's
doing it whatever story is telling it
it's a trilogy and then he's done
whereas they're bringing in the Game of
Thrones guys Benioff and Weiss are gonna
be working on something that could just
keep on going so and I it's also been no
they're not directing they are producing
and writing so it looks like Kathleen
Kennedy wants something that you know an
ongoing series that will be shepherded
by this so she doesn't have to do it
directly or I mean again putting on my
Sena cap for a second maybe people above
her pay grade are starting to doubt her
ability to be the main Shepherd of this
series and they want her to maybe
continue to work with Rian Johnson on
his because they got on really well but
you know have other people shepherding
other stuff I know that's the case but
you know tossing out possibilities so
these guys set up conceive and put into
motion on an ongoing series where other
directors can come in and out and who I
mean who knows where it's gonna go and
how it's gonna work but into my mind
what they're gonna start working on is
what will become the Star Wars
perpetuity that thus that the numbered
saga was initially
because like I said I mean how do you
keep telling Skywalker stories forever I
mean eventually it's just like let these
people retire and I I mean that both in
terms of the characters and the actors
like just give them a break so this will
probably be the new every two years we
get a new one of these type thing and
then they'll have this and they'll have
Ryan Johnson's trilogy and once that's
done they'll set up something else
assuming that these movies are still
making money at this point because now
we're talking like eight ten years down
the line by that point so who knows
where everything is by then but overall
while I can I can read a lot of cynicism
into the move
I don't feel too bad about it
I feel relatively positive on it all
things considered because as far as the
future this franchise goes I think it's
good to move away from the Skywalker's I
know some people are like Star Wars
isn't the Skywalker's it isn't for me
and I I think the how successful the
expanding universe was before Disney
declared a non cannon shows that for a
lot of people it doesn't begin an end
with the Skywalker so I still think
there's plenty of places to go and I
think removing the baggage of the
Skywalker's will free them up a bit more
to be able to go in directions and not
not risk as much backlash has happened
with the last Jedi so yeah more Star
Wars movies different creative team guys
you can forget about it having the
flavor of Game of Thrones with like all
the nudity and the vibes like that's not
why they're bringing these guys on
they're bringing these guys on because
they have gotten very adept at handling
massive ongoing projects so that's why
they're being brought on for this so
those are my thoughts on the latest Star
Wars news what are your thoughts on it
feel positive if you feel negative you
don't really know how you feel whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
stuff to do like say support me on
patreon I've got swag now check it out
sweet buttons business cards things like
that or you know just whatever you want
to do I appreciate it I love my patrons
and there's also you know Twitter and a
podcast and all that stuff links for all
these things are down below
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]